in so many cases a comparatively small
number of people were able to wreak so
much damage and spread so much fear in
our communities but you shouldn't allow
hope and optimism to be suffocated by
fear and pessimism we need to learn more
to do and there's nowhere where they
need more done than in tottenham a
community with so many victims of the
riots some met nick clegg last week and
were keen to hear his big idea about
payback you will see people invisible
orange clothing making up for the damage
done repairing and improving the
neighborhood's affected stephen moore
lost his business to the looters and
arsonists and he likes the prospect of
offenders coming back here to do a
little penance on the streets it's a
good idea to be especially if they're
wearing visible jackets and people can
look on him and actually may be coming
to what life is let them see the
majority of paper whatever Satan sky use
followed eva-maria hess last weekend as
she returned to the burned-out remains
of her home salvaging the few
possessions left if nick clegg gets his
way she'll get to meet the criminals who
talk so much from her all the additional
money provided to ensure that victims if
they want can face a confront their
offenders she wants to do it to look
them in the eyes but not for vengeance
but understanding people that you know
put us in the situation hopefully will
open up and understand what we went
through and we'll have to go through for
the next couple of weeks and months and
hopefully the people that got affected
by it
we'll try and step back and have a look
at these people that did it and ask
themselves why they did it there is
enthusiastic legs Commission on the
rioting people want a voice and they
want their opinions to be heard but his
most radical proposal is to for
offenders in to work on leaving prison
those offenders as they leave prison we
put through a tough process so that they
find work and they stay on the straight
and narrow for those who've been on the
inside the notion that people can be met
at the prison gate and told what to do
is fanciful he's doing this at the wrong
point in the sentence he said a way to
lunch in people come out of prison and
forcing them into work let's do it on
the very first day they go into jail the
problem with legs issue is what you do
if they stick two fingers up at the end
of the sentence and say I'm not doing it
but citing the fact that sixty percent
of those involved in the rioting were
already known to the police Nick Clegg
says something has to be done to break
the cycle of crime and he reckons he's
the man to help do it Michelle covered
Sky News Tottenham